excuse me who do you think you are
[Music]
[Music]
that's true our royal blood goes back
hundreds of years every villain has a
reason for doing the things they do and
Audrey is no exception
sure she's the queen of mean and she
blames mal for all of her problems but
Audrey's issue started way before the
BK's ever stepped foot in auradon
princess Audrey his girlfriend keep
watching to find out all about Audrey's
sad backstory and why her grandmother
might be to blame for her hideous
behavior princess Audrey is Sleeping
Beauty's daughter and she doesn't let
anyone forget it
she's a total name-dropper and she
expects to be treated as a royal no
matter what Audrey's got a wicked sense
of entitlement and it didn't just appear
overnight in Audrey's royal return she
tells her beautician that I was princess
girlfriend on the fast track to becoming
his wife in the Queen then she says that
her life was set and it was everything
her family wanted for her well what
exactly does this mean normal parents
want their kids to be happy above all
else and they definitely don't want them
to marry someone for status alone
but Audrey makes it sound as though
prince Aurora and Prince Phillip
desperately want their daughter to
become the queen of word on and we're
guessing that Audrey's grandmother Queen
Leah wants this more than anybody after
all she was a queen before Beast Belle
and fairy godmother created the United
States of auradon with this in mind
Audrey was probably groomed for the
throne ever since she was a little kid
being a princess just wasn't good enough
no one hates the villains more than
Queen Leah a chance to work pin destroy
us after all
Maleficent did curse her daughter and
threatened the foundations of her royal
bloodline so if her granddaughter one
day became the queen of auradon then
surely she would have a hand in keeping
the barrier closed Audrey had plans to
marry Prince Ben and become Queen aboard
on way before Mao came along but whether
she really had feelings for Ben is upper
to be sure she might think of him as
dreamy but did she love him for who he
was or what he could offer her it's
possible that Audrey's parents and
grandmother convinced Audrey to date Ben
from the
very young age this way they've gained
more status and be able to call the
shots it's easy to see that Audrey is
pretentious stuck-up and downright mean
I have to stick with royalty it makes
communication so much easier but these
aren't qualities that people develop on
their own usually children mimic those
around them so Audrey might have taken a
page out of Queen Leah's book you know
you're a nice person when you have
status in the bag but still care about
the little people but that's just not
the case for Audrey in Audrey's royal
return we see how Audrey treats the spa
staff and it isn't pretty she's bossy
and rude and constantly talking about
herself audrey confirms that she comes
to the spa often and immediately demands
special treatment so we can only imagine
that she's gone to this spa with her
family before and watched them treat the
staff the exact same way more sparkles
before Ben chose to bring four decays to
Oregon he and Audrey had been dating for
quite a while but everything changed
when he saw now for the very first time
a little bit Audrey made it a point to
challenge Evie's royal title which was
super rude and she didn't miss her
chance to flaunt her position at the
school before the bee case came around
Audrey was the most popular girl in
school but she also had a reputation for
being a mean girl but the table's turned
when Audrey was publicly humiliated by
Ben when he professed his love her mouth
instead of being sad and mourning her
relationship Audrey immediately started
dating Chad proving that she doesn't
date people out of love but out of
necessity in her eyes she has a
reputation to protect and dating a
fellow royal is of great importance
we know that Princess Aurora and Prince
Philip married each other because they
fell in love because whether they loved
each other or not they were already
betrothed to one another
Queen Liam must have made the
arrangement as soon as Aurora was born
proving that she doesn't believe in
marrying for love either so we're
guessing she's the one who put this
notion into Audrey's head when we first
meet Queen Leah she comes off as sweet
innocent but it only takes a few seconds
for her to create some drama despite now
having nothing to do with her mother's
actions Audrey and Leah team up on her
within an instant one look at Queen
Leah's outfit is all we need to know
that she's all about appearances Queen
Leah makes a scene and makes mal feel
bad for no reason at all which just
isn't classy since Queen Leah didn't get
to raise her daughter due to Maleficent
curse she most definitely made it a
point to help raise Audrey we're pretty
convinced that Audrey takes after her
grandmother after all Princess Aurora
was raised by fairies and turned out to
be a wonderful girl Audrey's plans to
marry King Ben have become the queen
blew up in her face and now she's the
queen of mean and nothing else by the
end of Audrey's royal return she makes
it clear that she believes her makeover
to be enough to win Ben back but in the
official trailer Ben proposes to mal
which foils her plans once again oddly
enough we couldn't help but notice that
Queen Leah was equally as stunned as her
granddaughter during the announcement
just look out of her face this sad truth
is that Audrey was groomed for the
throne since she was a kid and now
she'll stop at nothing to become the
queen she was raised to be do you think
Queen Leah is to blame for Audrey's
wicked personality sound off in the
comments and that's a wrap thanks for
watching the things don't forget to Like
and subscribe we'll catch you later
[Music]